and so let's get started today is the
sadly the last day of the boot camp [ __ ]
you know at the end we have the best so
today this session is kicked off by a
Stephanie [ __ ] and she will talk
about connections between some other
accommodations the very discrete topic
and first of all the metals contingent
is okay thank you so this is lecture
three in the series on continuous
methods on discrete optimization and
since that modular optimization is a
very rich topic to show sort of
interactions between continuous and
discrete optimization in various
different ways so let me just show you a
bunch of examples sort of in this topic
how you can actually take this discrete
optimization problem and transform it to
a continuous optimization problem and
actually also vice versa so envious Lee
there has been a lot of work on sub
modularity and optimization and we have
lots of experts also here in this
workshop so my goal here is not to give
you sort of a laundry list of all the
best possible results and bounce you can
get but more sort of convey some of the
main ideas how you get to some of these
results and how you
and again if you have any questions
please ask if I'm going too fast or too
slow please let me know okay so let's
get started so first of all what is this
app modular function that model arity
can actually define pretty broadly but
let's start with the notion of a set
function and submodular set function so
that function means we have a discrete
collection of items that we call the
ground said we and we can take subsets s
of these items and we have a set
function that assigns values to all of
these items so that's our set function
and we will want to maximize or minimize
this function depending on whether this
is a cost function or probability or
utility function or something like that
so now in general this can be a very
hard problem any of your favorite
np-hard problems you can probably phrase
in this way and then say you want to
minimize or maximize such a function so
we need some properties that make it a
bit nicer so one such property is
sub-module arity what is sub modularity
there's basically two ways to define it
here the may be more intuitive faced by
our diminishing returns
so diminishing returns means the
following that I have already selected a
set s and I see how much does my
function increase when I add one more
item to a to my set so this is the
marginal game and as my set s grows so
if I take a larger set I may add the
same item a the marginal gain can never
increase so basically the more I know
the less I gain from one more item of
information or if I already have a cap
may be getting one additional cap is
actually not so valuable but if I don't
have any then this one cap is actually
very valuable to me so you can think of
it that way it also models economies of
scale if you think about typically
producing larger amount this cheaper on
average then producing smaller amounts
and so on so this is why these functions
have also been important in economics ok
I already wrote this the same definition
over there because we will need it over
and over again so this is diminishing
returns or diminishing marginal gains
okay so that's one way to define it
anything it's pretty intuitive you maybe
already see that several problems may
have the scheme of property there's an
alternative way of defining sub
modularity that's actually equivalent
and we will need both of these so I'm
showing you both the second one is here
we say okay S has to be a subset of T
and we sort of look at this marginal
gains and in fact you can think of this
marginal gains also as a discrete
derivative so if you think of this as a
discrete derivative this is a bit like
as my set grows my derivative should
shrink so it's a little bit like
concavity in a discrete set so here's
the other definition other definition
says I take two arbitrary sets a and B
and if I evaluate F at a and FFP that
should be large or equal then F at a
union B plus effort a intersect B so
these are equivalent I'm claiming so to
see that they are equivalent you just
have to do some rearrangement so one
direction you can prove as follows you
say a is the same as as Union a B is the
same as T and then you just know that
the union of the two will be that large
set with T Union a and the intersection
will be s and you see by rearrangement
this implies this the other direction
you can prove by induction so this
actually fairly straightforward yes
right now we don't need non negativity
and they actually can be positive or
negative when we may need it later on
when we talk about maximization right
now this works for anything essentially
let me just write down this also so that
we can remember it you don't need to
keep it in the head so for all its a and
B you need that F of a plus F of B
so far so good so we have the definition
but why do we care about these functions
and to give you a little bit of
intuition let me take a quote from a
paper from the 18th this was a seminal
paper by lost all of us when you looked
at relations between sub modular
functions and convexity so first he
argued why do we care about convex
functions via convex functions so
important well in pretty much everywhere
and he says well there's basically a few
different points one since they occur in
many models in economy engineering and
other sciences and they are often the
only non-trivial property that can be
stated in general so pretty much like
very generic it's widely applicable
second you can do many transformations
so they are preserved under many
operations and transformations not so
that gives you a larger effective range
of results if you prove something for a
convex function you can transform it you
can derive others it's gonna still hold
the third one is they still have so they
are rightly applicable and they have a
sufficient structure for a
mathematically beautiful and practically
useful theory and the fourth one is you
can do efficient minimization so some of
these are more conceptual and some are
actually also like more actually I'm a
bit more mathematical points and then he
goes on and he says well it is less
apparent but we claim and hope to prove
to a certain extent that a similar role
is played in discrete optimization by
sub modular set functions so this is
more of his conceptual connection but in
this paper actually he goes on and he
makes some more formal connections to
and in fact it's true that all the last
point holds and there's actually very
crisp formal connections also between
sub modularity and convexity as we will
see so that was in this paper we will
get back to this paper over and over
again so before we get to that those
connections in a bit more detail let me
show you something about the first point
so what are some examples of functions
that actually have the sub modularity
property just briefly
so obviously linear functions if you
have just every item has a weight and
you sum up the weights of the items that
you pick that's a linear function that
satisfies all these inequalities over
there with equality very simple example
but there's others more interesting
examples may be so for example entropy
of discrete random variables if you take
the grounds had to be a collection of
random variables entered as the function
you take the joint entropy of these
variables that's going to be as a
modular function and similarly mutual
information
then some other examples is if your
items are actually vectors and you pick
these items and you put them together in
a matrix and you measure the rank so
matrix rank functions that's going to be
a submodular function and also more
combinatorial generalizations thereof so
metroid rank functions michelle had
mentioned Metroid's so they also have
something like a rank 4 they have rank
functions if you know what they are and
these also satisfy that modularity so
think of them as a combinatorial
generalization of rank then functions
like average functions so max cover is a
sub model a maximization problem you can
see very easily that coverage functions
where I select maybe some sets and that
covers some area or some other items
that's going to have the diminishing
returns properties the more I've already
covered the less again from choosing
more set and very similarly actually
diffusion in network so if I pick some
seed notes in the network and I see how
does maybe information spread and I look
at what sort of the area are the nodes
that have covered in expectation is like
a randomized cover also has sub
modularity property volume functions
that are defined by determinants and
also an important one graph cuts so
minimum cut problem is a submodular
minimization problem where here we are
picking notes in a graph and we are
measuring the edges that we have to cut
to select is not okay that's just a few
applications I'm not going to talk much
about like more applications or
instances of these I'm going to talk
more about sort of optimization
okay so what am I going to talk about
today so first of all I'm going to show
you how do these sub modular functions
connect to continuous optimization have
how we can exploit continuous
optimization to do sub modular
optimization and then in the end I will
also talk a little bit more about the
other direction that actually there's
also examples where you can do
continuous optimization via discrete
optimization and looking at sub
modularity a bit more generally big
beyond set functions but you see that
many of these ideas will occur here
again and if we have time I talked a
little bit about other connections
between sub modularity and continuous
functions and optimization okay so let's
start with optimizing a submodular
function so we have this discrete set
function it's a very discrete
optimization problem how do we optimize
this function and I just said optimize
there's two ways I might want to
optimize that I want to minimize it or
maximizing of course this is very
different and I may need different
methods for minimization or maximization
and some question that will actually
become sort of a question that we will
encounter throughout the talk as well
it's that model in real arity more like
convexity or concavity if you think
about minimization you would like this
function to be as convex as possible
because we know how to do convex
minimization but convex maximization is
not so easy so if we actually want to
maximize it we would rather run this
function to be s concave as possible so
that's like how we will use it and in
fact there has been a debate about this
so I showed you that paper by Lovaas in
that same paper he actually also shows
connections to concavity and argues that
actually submodular functions also have
very close connections to concavity and
I already hinted at something if you
look at the diminishing returns
that's like discrete concavity and in
fact if you define a sec function in a
way that you say I take the cardinality
of the set and I take a scalar function
of that cardinality that thing is a
modeler if and only if that scalar
function is concave
so there's close connections also to
concavity but there's also close
connections to convexity so I hinted at
it and actually to give you one more
hint if you look at this inequality and
if you know the definition of midpoint
convexity and you sort of view these two
as some kind of average of your sets
then this is a little bit reminiscent of
mid-con midpoint convexity there's going
to be a more formal connection too and
so food is again a paper road they said
yeah somehow some modular functions
there looks like discrete concavity but
if you look at duality results they
always somehow the inequality is always
written the wrong way for that so they
always occur on the wrong side so in
that sense they are more like convex and
we'll get to that and indeed there's
even a notion of discrete convexity
really which generalizes some modularity
that was studied by mu rota okay so too
much for the disk concavity convexity
relations and we'll encounter these so
now let's see how could we use
continuous optimization for sub modular
optimization so I'm talking about
continuous method so let's look at
continuous now the first thing to notice
is that well we have the set function
but maybe for continuous relaxations or
reformulations it's more convenient to
think about vectors then subsets and
obviously there's a very close
connection between vectors and subsets
we just take indicator vector so
basically for each item and have a
coordinate X I if I pick that item X is
1 otherwise X is 0 so I can equivalently
write my function as a function of
binary vectors one-to-one correspondence
is just the same so now the question is
how could I take this problem and make
it a continuous optimization problem
so well one way to do continuous
optimization problem is to an LP
relaxation so but there's basically not
an easy way to write this problem is
some kind of C transpose X because f is
nonlinear so it's very special case it's
linear but most like mostly like if you
have this strict diminishing returns is
not going to be a linear function so
you're not easily gonna get this out you
can't do a linear programming relaxation
what you have to do is you'd pick one
variable for each subset and basically
use this as indicator variables say they
have to sum up to one and then you just
take the evaluations of the function you
got a linear program out it's very
simple in your program it's exponential
size you can do it and in fact what we
will do is very closely related it's
sort of you can view it as a collapsed
version of this but let's look at
something else than the linear
programming relaxation and that means
okay we will have to do a nonlinear
program so what we will try to do is we
will find a nonlinear function so we
will relax now this to the hyper cube
and find a function that we can evaluate
on vectors that have entries between 0 1
and that we can somehow optimize instead
and then somehow go back to the other
side so that's a plan
so how to do this what could be this
function and let me just show you the
picture and let's see what we would we
want from such a function so here
basically the thing is I have two items
in 2d so I have one dimension for each
item and if I have two items there's
four subsets I could pick nothing a B or
a and B together so this will be 0 0 1 0
0 1 or 1 1 so my function can really be
evaluated only on like the corners of
the hypercube so what what I want from
this function little F so for once I
would maybe want it to be somehow close
to my discrete function so maybe I would
want it to coincide with my discrete
function at least on the discrete points
and otherwise be somehow close that if I
have a solution on this side I can
somehow go back to a solution on this
side I know I'm not losing too much and
the second thing is that this little
function little F should somehow be easy
to optimize otherwise it's not so useful
so what could this function be so if I
just say I want an interpolation of
these points that somehow a continuous
function in fact there's many different
ways I could do this infinitely many
ways in fact and the question is which
of these functions actually has these
other properties that are useful for
optimization and somehow useful for
rounding in some way and here it's the
difference if I want to do minimization
or maximization so let's focus on
minimization for the moment so maybe I
would want this to be somehow easy to
minimize
so here's a generic construction how we
could reach it such an extension or
continuous function that interpolates
our our sub modular function so we know
we can evaluate our submodular function
on discrete vectors and now I have a
continuous vector and I want to want a
function that I can evaluate here that
has something to do with that function
one way to do it and this is actually an
old trick is to say well I've used these
fractional entries here as probabilities
so I somehow say that this vector Z here
means that I choose a with probability
0.5 I choose B with probability 0.5 and
D with probability point 8 and then I
say ok this gives me a probability
distribution and I'll take expectation
under this distribution that gives me a
continuous function so formally what we
will do is we will define a probability
measure over subsets or over binary
vectors such that the marginals agree
with Z that means the probability that
is 1 equals CI and then our extension is
going to be the expectation under this
probability so that's going to be a
continuous function it's going to be
defined on all the Z's and obviously if
Z is binary these probabilities will be
deterministic so I will actually
coincide with my set function
so it's this well defined
so it smell defined up to something and
the something is that well I said the
marginal should agree with Z but what is
the Joint Distribution I can have many
different joint distributions that have
to say marginals I haven't specified
that yet and depending on what is the
Joint Distribution I will get out
different extensions here so that is the
important thing to notice so well let's
look at some joint distributions and see
what comes out so simplest joint
distribution would be to say they're
independent that's the most remote
straightforward thing to try so let's
try that which means that the
probability of a certain set is exactly
this I flip a coin for each of these
that's the easiest one so what what
happens with this one
the first thing that's easy to notice is
this is actually going to be a
polynomial in the so-called multi linear
polynomial and it's also called the
multi linear extension of the submodular
function now if you think about
optimization here's a picture in 2d this
is what it looks like in 2d for my
example function you see this is not
really convex it's not really concave it
looks a bit like a saddle point function
here so maybe if I would want this to be
a relaxation for my minimization problem
this is gonna cause some trouble if I
actually want to minimize this guy it's
not useless it's just right now not so
useful for minimization so what we
actually would like is something that is
like looks like a convex function here
the question is can we get this with our
definition with these expectations can
we get something that somehow nice and
possibly convex and easy to minimize and
in fact you can but it's maybe not
obvious it's actually not obvious how
you get to that let me just show you the
construction and then argue why this
should be something that has good
properties here's the construction again
we have our marginals we want the
marginals to coincide but this time we
correlate the variables pretty much very
strongly by what I call level sets so
here you can think of it this way that
you think of this as a histogram or
mountains so we have like 0.5 lengths
here we have point eight lengths here
and now we randomly draw a threshold
between zero one and we pick all the
items that exceed that threshold so here
I'm picking a B and D so you see
actually this car lets them a lot
because I can always either pick them
together or not pick them together and
in fact they're so only here in this
particular case there's only three sets
I can pick nothing D abies D and if the
C was bigger than zero I could pick that
out that's it versus if I pick them
independently I can pretty much reach
any site unless I have a zero in there
that's a big difference so in that sense
actually that expectation is easier to
compute I have only at most and many
sets that I can even sample and I call
this the level sets because you get them
sort of you think of these as mountains
that sort of the heights
if you cut your mountains at different
heights so these are the level sets and
this particular construction is also
called the Chaka integrals of the set
function so again plus to Inverness this
is relatively easy to compute by just
computing these levels that you can get
by sorting by what it's not so obvious
is why should this have any good
properties why is this useful for
optimization and in fact it is not
obvious because here for example this I
can define for any set function actually
like the other one I haven't used sub
modularity at all up till here but this
is a convex function if and only if the
set function is a submodular function so
here's our close connection to convexity
this is the if and only if if this is
the convex function the set function bas
is a modular function and vice versa and
this is actually what it looks like in
our picture so now this looks like
something that may be useful for
optimization because it's convex at
least so convex minimization I know how
to do and it's a were a pretty simple
set so I may know how to do it
but is there maybe not so pieces why
should this hold how would why would
this be a convex function so let me give
you a little bit of an intuition why
this what is actually the connection
that you can see that this is should be
a convex function which would be sort of
a hint on one direction so to see this
let's take a closer look how you
actually what is the evaluation of this
so I said you have these level sets as
you sort of take your threshold and you
go through here and in that expectation
you have to use each of them and use a
combination of these with weights so
what's going to be that combination
so here so how to compute this is if I
take my vector Z and I sort it from
large to small entries so I'd say I just
remembered the coordinates so I say Z 1
is bigger than C 2 and so on up to the N
so I sort it and now what is this this
guy here basically in that case f of Z
is the end times the full set that's
basically when the threshold is sort of
up until it hits the first of these the
smallest of my entries and then what's
the next time I said change is basically
when I hit the next of my values
and so on up to Z 1 minus Z 2 so roughly
this is what this expectation is going
to look like these are all non-negative
because I have sorted them
and it's a nonnegative combination of my
function value so I can actually also
write this as an inner product of my
vector Z with some vector s that depends
on some evaluations of the function my
function at different sets are actually
differences of these evaluations just by
looking at the evaluation okay so why
does this show convexity and in fact
here's why this actually shows convexity
if my function is of modular this little
vector S is actually exactly the same as
the solution to an optimization problem
which is a maximization problem where Z
is the cost function and this s lives in
a special polytope so I'll say something
about that but what this means is that
this f of Z is actually equivalent to a
point mass maximum of linear functions
and a point wise maximum of linear
functions is convex and you see actually
it's also a piecewise linear function
and that's exactly what this looks like
so this shows it's convex how you prove
this is Phi LP duality by noticing that
this is actually the optimal solution so
what is this guy here this bf this bf is
a very special poly tope average
submodular function has a special poly
tope associated with it and this poly
tope is defined by the submodular
function so it's defined it's called the
base poly tope and it's defined as the
set of all vectors in RN such that that
are essentially dominated by my sub
modulus function so for all subsets T V
basically I sum up all the items I view
this as a linear function and should be
dominated by myself modular function and
the entire thing should sum up to
submodular function evaluated at the
full set and you see it has actually
exponentially many inequalities these
are defined by the f of peace or f of
esses and here basically we get the
tight inequalities out so that's why you
get actually these f of s these are
basically the right-hand sides here the
amazing thing is that this is a polytope
that has exponentially many inequalities
all of which can be valid but you can do
very easy optimization over this
polytope as you see you just need to do
sorting and that's it so n log N and
you're done and you have seen special
instances of these polytopes so examples
of the probability simplex so called
perimeter he drawn the spanning tree
polytope any kind of Metroid polytope
and so they all have this property
actually they all are instances of these
based polytopes and this specific fact
that you can do this linear optimization
over the base polytope in n log n time
or polynomial time essentially underlies
essentially all the tractability of sub
modular minimization we can do this we
can compute this that means we can
compute this and this has many other
implications ok so this is a very
important insight now we have an
extension that's convex can we use it
for optimization so one thing we might
want to do if we do optimization is well
if you think about the simple simplest
optimization thing is run a gradient
descent method or in this case up
gradient method because this is not
differentiable we need to be able to
compute the sub gradient what is the sub
gradient of this function is not obvious
from the expectation but it's obvious
from here you compute the arc max that's
going to be your sub gradient so it's
easy to do we know how to do it so it's
easy to compute the sub gradient that
means we can do at the very least a sub
gradient optimization project its sub
gradient method or something like that
very first thing we could do here
so we can optimize this function and we
can do something smarter than
subgradient method but we can know that
the second question is if we have
minimized this function how do we get
back to a discrete solution because
that's what we actually want yes so if
it's a sub-module
if it is basically a base polytope you
will get a submodular function out so
you can actually define your submodular
function via this poly tour by saying i
have a function where this is a binary
vector and I define a function that's
exactly defined like this for binary
vector so you get a set function out
that is that modular only if this has
essentially the base pollito properties
yes if it's a mate right poly tope this
is going to be sub modular that's not a
sub much yeah that's not going to be a
sub mode of function that also you
cannot do greedy optimization over so
mate right intersection or like even
more matrix it's not going to be optimal
if you do just a greedy simple algorithm
by sorting so this is actually this
greedy optimization is very closely
related to the base product of
properties good question
so what about rounding so let's say we
have the optimal solution z star
how do we get to a discrete solution and
now actually we can realize that what
would be little F of Z star it's
actually just a combination of function
evaluations with non-negative
coefficients so if this guy is the
minimum one of these level sets at least
has to be the minimum we're actually all
of them so we can if we have an optimal
solution z star we basically just look
at this level set so we do threshold
rounding essentially and find the best
levels that in fact you can take all the
entries that have value bigger than 0
that's going to give you a minimum so
rounding is super easy
optimization is relatively easy at least
we can do a sub gradient so we actually
have an exact convex relaxation for this
optimization problem so we have a way to
take our fairly complex up modular
function and transform it into a convex
optimization problem where we know how
to round it back to an optimal discrete
solution if we know how to do this and
this now is the convex optimization
problem where we know how to get a sub
gradient it's over a very simple convex
set so now we can take all what we have
learned about convex optimization in
this we can use anything we like that
applies to this non smooth optimization
problem so we can get many different
algorithms out yes I'm not exactly sure
but this leads to the what is called the
convex envelope which is the largest
convex function that essentially fits
underneath your function so this is in
some sense the closest convex function
you can get
and the other question
okay so with this let me just give you a
very abbreviated overview of what you
can do to now optimize this Lovis
extension or subdue submodular
minimization the very first method that
was applied here that actually showed
proof that you can do some model
minimization in polynomial time was the
ellipsoid method noticing when this came
out that you can actually run the
ellipsoid method it was by far not a
practical algorithm but it proved
polynomial time which was a big thing
and open certain open question at the
time then of course another example is
this a gradient method as I pointed to
which will give you not exactly a
polynomial time algorithm so if you want
say a gap F epsilon between the optimum
and your solution you have need one of
over 100 of one over epsilon squared
durations but it can it's very easy to
do this and there's also improved
versions with a stochastic sub gradient
methods more recent ones yes
foundational function what you wrote to
the board yes
oh this is the full set so this is
basically s and
so if you think about say you have this
vector that gives you this histogram of
like the different things so you take
your threshold this is going to be s0 is
going to be empty set these are all the
possible sets you can sample so what you
want is the expectation of s what is the
expectation of F of s it's basically the
sum over all subsets the probability of
the set times the F of s what's the
probability of achieving that set
sampling that's at so basically what
this would be is sum over all subsets
probability of sampling that set times
the function evaluated at this set right
this is just the definition of
expectation so the question is what is
this probability under the distribution
we defined so the distribution we
defined was that we pick a random
threshold between 0 1 so here's 0 here's
1 uniformly at random and we would
whichever like if it hits this bar we're
going to pick only this item s or
exactly and if the threshold is small
enough it's going to hit all of them and
this is basically the smallest entry in
my vector so this is going to be there
that's why every step the the s on the
third line is different from the esses
on the previous line so inner product Z
comma s oh yeah yeah so this you could
say this is a different vector yeah
that's not a set let's call this Y
there's some yeah on the board capital
and little s yeah yeah that's true yeah
so I yeah you're right yes or I could
assume that F of the empty set for
simplicity is 0 you're right I should
have done that we're about - the largest
value and then you're still missing
any other questions about the extension
okay so let's go back to the overview so
we have our extension we have the convex
relaxation how to optimize it there's
various different ways you can use
convex optimization methods you can
actually also use combinatorial
optimization so there's also
combinatorial optimization methods which
was essentially motivated by the fact
that say minimum cut or so are special
cases of sub modular minimization and we
have good combinatorial algorithms for
them is there comm unit or ela algorithm
for this problem so I'm writing this
year these are actually coming at Oriel
methods why am i writing them here
essentially you can view them as
optimizing the convex dual of this
problem so what is going to be the
convex tool of this problem it's going
to be convex minimization of a convex
set it's going to be concave
maximization over some convex set so the
convex set that we have here's the base
polytope that they optimize over so it's
a some more complex thing and we have
some non smooth convex function concave
functions simple function we are
optimizing the function is essentially
we want to maximize
the coordinate wise maximum between zero
and si so basically we want as few
negative entries in our vector as
possible so now so far so good the only
complication here is that this set is
easy to do linear optimization over but
anything else like testing membership in
the set doing a projection on the set or
any such thing corresponds to solving a
submodular minimization problem so all
of these are things that we want to
avoid this like a chicken and egg
problem
otherwise it won't be concave so how do
you move in this poly tope that's the
key question because the function is
easy but the key question is how do you
move in this poly tope and stay in it
without ever testing membership so what
these algorithms do is they essentially
use network flow algorithms to make sure
they still satisfy the constraints and
they move in this poly tope and they
essentially move or remove as much
negative mass as possible from the
vectors so that's there's a very very
high level intuition of what this
combinatorial algorithms do there's a
lot more ideas behind this than what I'm
super simplifying here but the main idea
is that you use network flow strategies
to move in as poly tope without ever
testing membership that's essentially
what they do so this is how this relates
to actually this problem it's like
solving the dual with a combinatorial
method and then if you want strongly
polynomial time algorithms you can also
do a combination of convex and
combinatorial disss and there are some
more recent results and maybe Erin will
tell you later this afternoon about
their approach their improvement you
want okay anyways it was your work so
yeah okay yeah yeah so basically
improvements to cutting plane method
sleep to further improvement in the in
the best running times M is the maximum
function value and T is the time to
evaluate a function
okay and of course you can think of
other ways to do it this is sort of a
brief overview so you see this actually
it's a very interesting comment well
things you can do the quick one other
question is how far does this relaxation
go and let me show you one positive and
one negative result so one interesting
positive result is that relaxation is
actually quite rich in the sense that I
can even make it strongly convex and I
can still read out the optimal solution
so what I can do is I can say this
actually this piecewise linear function
doesn't have such good optimization
properties maybe I want this to be
strongly convex so I'm adding a strongly
convex separable function to it I'm
removing the constraint and I'm
minimizing this you can't generalize
this definition to more than the
hypercube it's not obvious that you
would see the discrete optimal solution
from the optimal solution of this
obviously this has a different optimal
solution from this one because I can
make actually the effect to arbitrarily
large but still you can actually do
optimal rounding for this one and the
key insight here is that all we really
need is again this level set so all we
really here need here is which entries
are positive and that's actually the
same question that we have over here
which entries are positive and these are
actually the same
and it's people up to this and the other
interesting thing is now we can again
look at the convex dual the convex tool
is a very geometric problem it finds
essentially through the projection of 0
onto my base polytope where that finds
the point with a smallest norm on the
base polytope and this optimization
problem leads to what's called the
minimum no point algorithm or the Fuji
she give off algorithm by applying a
specific variant of the framework method
were the wolfes method essentially to
solving this problem finding the minimum
nor mind in a polytope yes outside the
zero one
Oh eventually you can go by this sorting
definition and you're just this sorting
definite like if you just say you have
this definition with the sorting or the
definition with a point wise maximum of
these conrick of these linear functions
that extends so the you can no longer
easily interpret it as an expectation
but this max over linear function makes
sense know the minimum of this guy most
likely will have negative entries so you
no longer have here feasible region it
doesn't matter because you can extend
that definition and you take all the
entries that have positive values were
no negative actually works in this case
and you can prove that's optimal the
reason this is actually optimal is
because this problem solves a richer set
of problem it solves what's called
parametric minimization which means
minimize f of s plus alpha times
cardinality of s for all alphas and you
can read out these solutions from
basically the level sets of that thing
so without the penalty alpha equals zero
you'll get the optimal solution so this
is just a curious connection this is the
same as why you can do for example
parametric max flow so efficiently this
is same underlying ideas essentially so
just to mention this this leads to us to
another sort of class of algorithms for
solving problems like this for doing a
parallelization and so on
I said I'll show you also negative
results so one thing where all of this
framework breaks is if I say I don't
want to optimize over the hypercube but
I have more constraints I want sets of
size at most K so or some other
constraints on my set all of these
problems essentially become not only
np-hard they become even hard to
approximate basically polynomial lower
bounds on the approximation factors for
pretty much all of these problems of
constraints of modular minimization and
in that case I cannot get a tight convex
relaxation anymore I can't do this and I
can use it as a relaxation and then try
to do rounding but it's no longer going
to be giving me the exact optimum so but
that at least up to here it's a it's a
pretty useful and nice a framework and
actually this is a very efficient
algorithm in practice in general ok so I
have a little bit more time I wanted to
show you some other ideas so let me show
you a little bit about sub modular
maximization I talked a lot about
minimizing submodular functions let me
talk a little bit about maximization so
for maximization that problem already in
itself is np-hard so we cannot expect to
get anything exact out of it so think of
Max cover max cut these are instances of
sub modular maximization problems and
obviously not solvable exactly in poly
time
yeah we can hope to get approximations
and actually in most cases we can get
very good constant factor approximation
here we have to make essentially some
distinction so here we have to care
about see if the function is
non-negative here let's assume it's
non-negative and there's another
distinction that is the function
monotone increasing meaning as my set
grows the function value only increases
or can the function be arbitrary
so coverage function would be increasing
a cut function can be decreasing as well
so for maximization if we're in I call
these simple cases basically I have a
monotone function I have a constraint I
don't want to pick more than K a simple
discrete greedy algorithm actually gives
me the theoretical optimum which means a
1 minus 1 over Y approximation so
algorithm is very simple I start with
the empty set I picked the best item by
its value and then I pick the best
augmentation etc etc until 1/2 came so
super simple algorithm it gives me 1
minus 1 over E and the key idea
improving this is to show that in every
iteration you close the gap to the
optimum by a certain factor that depends
on 1 over K but then if you talk about
more complex constraints or you talk
about non monotone optimization this
algorithm is no longer optimal and in
that case is when we may hear about
doing continuous extensions and
relaxations and that can give you the
optimal vector so again we have the same
idea we have our discrete function
defined over set or binary vectors and
we want to find some kind of
interpolation that we will optimize and
then somehow try to do some rounding now
we have our low-pass extension which is
convex but if we want to do maximization
that may not be the right thing
convex maximization is not a very easy
thing to do
can we do something else so you could
think about where I could take like
maybe this is the convex envelope I
could take the concave envelope it
exists but unfortunately three hard to
compute it so it's not tractable so we
have to find something else and that
something else will actually be what we
saw in the beginning this independent
Joint Distribution so as I showed you
already in the picture this thing is not
a concave function but it'll turn out
that it has good enough properties that
you can say something non-trivial about
it and this something that this
non-trivial about it is actually the
same that the greedy algorithm hinges
upon in that is diminishing returns
we don't have concavity but we have
diminishing returns and that takes us
quite a long way so what diminishing
returns means is that if I now look at
this continuous function I take the
second derivatives the Hessian is
basically all negative all non positive
and the implications that this have is
that this function is concave in
increasing direction so if I start at
zero and I go in directions where my
entries increase you see this looks like
kind of concave and if I go in
directions that are swaps so basically
increasing one coordinate and decreasing
the other that's like this direction you
see it looks concave and it actually is
you can prove that follows from this
it's not very hard to prove it so this
is actually two very important
properties so what are we going to do we
are going to use this and we are going
to try and maximize it as well as we can
and in fact this is going to be a
continuous non convex maximization
because not rehman concave essentially
and then that's not going to give us the
optimum but it's going to get us in the
case for example for meet rate in a
constant factor of 1 minus 1 over E and
then we are going to do lossless
rounding how do we do rounding for
rounding let's say we have found some
point here we are going to use these
convex directions so if you think of a
constraint that says well maybe X I and
XJ have to sum up to something smaller
than a certain
you cannot arbitrarily increase both of
them if they already sum up to that so
you have to increase one and decrease
the other so you find two of them
increase one and decrease the other
enough you think about it it's concave
convex function in this direction along
a line so if you have a convex function
U at some point there's always one of
the directions your function is going to
increase so you can always find one
direction along your line of increasing
one and decreasing the other that you
are going to improve the function value
and that's the idea behind the rounding
here so that's actually a very important
property there was a question what is
like if you increase yeah you could do
it but then you don't know so if the way
you do the rounding is you only ever do
two at a time and same actually works
also for non monotone where there's
actually interesting from correspondence
between randomized greedy and continuous
optimization numbers so how does this
continuous optimization work let me just
show you one example which is in the
case when your function is monotone and
the constraint so what's called a
metroid constraint think of in the
simplest cases like still a budget
constraint like they should all sum up
to something smaller than K that's a
very simple example we have some poly
tope over which you can optimize and now
what this so-called continuous greedy
algorithm actually is doing is like you
lorenzo talked about the frank bolt
method it's essentially an instance of a
non convex Frank wolf method so how does
it work is you start at zero like the
greedy algorithm and now in every
iteration it finds a good direction to
go and that good direction to go through
better stay in your poly tope in your
feasible set so how do you ensure this
you find the direction or the corner of
your feasible poly tube that's most
aligned with the gradient gradient
itself you don't know how far you can go
until you go out of your constraints
that's not so good so you find the guy
that's most aligned with the gradient
that's sort of the best corner to what
you can go and then you go a little bit
into the direction of that corner and if
you set this correctly you're actually
gonna get always a convex combination of
corners and you're going to be inside
the polytope all the time
best idea so this is actually exactly
the same as the framework method with a
special twist of how you combine the
points in that you have to start at zero
in this particular case here yeah so
this is a different from the usual
convex optimization framework but it's
conceptually very close and in fact the
original paper didn't prove it that way
they used a differential equation and
discretized it but if you discretize it
this is essentially what I will I will
arguably depends how you set alpha
essentially the idea here is that you
start at zero and you set actually alpha
to 1 over capital T so in the end you
have taken T steps and in each step you
take a corner and you add it with
fraction 1 over T you do that T times
you get a convex combination yeah but it
depends how you survive okay so why does
it actually why is this good so let me
show you the analogy with the analysis
of the Frank wolf method so this is the
proof for my lecture notes when I first
talked about Frank wolf and then about
this method so here's the idea first
thing you do is Taylor approximation
this is the standard proof of
first-order Frank wolf optimization so
progress I make in each step so
basically by going to step T plus 1 I'm
at ly lower bounded by the previous
point plus the gradient times the
direction I went in to plus some
second-order terms this is just a Taylor
approximation so now what you typically
do is now you use this and you use
convexity and you show that this indeed
tells you that you're making sufficient
progress and you get the standard 1 over
T right
so here we don't have convexity but what
we have is diminishing returns which
gives you actually concavity in the
positive directions and showing this
what they showed in the paper is that
what you can show is that you there is a
point where the inner product gives you
that this inner product is upper bounded
by up - your current point so basically
the current gap so and we know that when
we are doing the arc max here we are
actually finding the best possible point
so we are certainly at least as good as
this because we're finding the arc mix
so we can just plug it in here just
replacing that inequality up there that
we got from diminishing returns and once
you have this you rearranged it and what
you see is that what this actually shows
you is that just with a greedy method in
every iteration you close the gap to the
optimum by a certain factor one minus
alpha and if you just now iterate this
and set alpha to 1 over T you get it and
this T goes to infinity this is going to
be 1 minus 1 over e and this is gonna go
to 0 so this is essentially in a
nutshell how you can show that this non
convex Frankel algorithm still gives you
a very decent approximation in practices
of demo in this case 1 minus 1 over E
and then you do rounding
so let me just with that sort of close
at heart and give you like the overview
of what we saw is that we can take this
sub modular optimization problem the
discrete problem can take different
types of relaxations depending if you
want to do maximization or minimization
and get exact or very good constant
factor approximation out of this
relaxation by carefully using the
properties and the key inside is use
convexity relaxations if you want to do
minimization use diminishing returns if
you want to do maximization so now I'm
almost out of time so I just let me just
sketch one more idea here and that is
how do these ideas generalize to
functions beyond sets so how does that
modularity generalize to functions
beyond sets well I already said you can
do sets as binary vectors and in fact
instead of binary vectors you could take
integer vectors or real vectors or
something so in that case that same
inequality becomes just a lattice
conditions where you take coordinate
wise maximum and coordinate wise minimum
and it's exactly the same definition the
question is what kinds of functions
satisfy this if I look at continuous
functions if I look at other discrete
functions what kind of functions are
functions that satisfy this kind of
inequality
and for a bit more understanding if
you're the function is differentiable
this is what it corresponds to that if
you look at the Hessian of the function
although off diagonals are non positive
but that also means this is actually not
it says nothing whether the Hessian is
definite in any way and in fact these
functions can be convex or concave or
neither so here's an example of such a
function so it contains convex functions
concave functions at night Kanaan convex
functions essentially so the key
question is to the results that I talked
about do they generalize in any ways to
these kinds of functions and in a
nutshell they do to a certain extent if
you want to do maximization we realized
all we need is diminishing returns
remember that's like what gave you the
concavity and so on diminishing returns
is not the same as sub modularity in
this general case it's slightly stronger
but if you have it so essentially if you
think about this negative prescient
condition all of the entries of the
Hessian have to be negative and then it
works and in that case you can pretty
much generalize oops
most of the maximization results in
particular discontinuous greedy method
that I said actually just relied on this
condition of the multi linear extension
yes yes we've got an approximation
factor like basically the same kinds of
approximation factor results out
the approximation factor was constant
didn't depend on the dimension that is
not for minimization the picture you
cannot do exact continuous optimization
at least I don't know of anything but
you can discretize it and once you have
discretized it you can actually use all
the ideas from discrete optimization for
example you can generalize the lowest
extension to this case with a bit more
effort it's going to become more complex
distribution you the coupling is done
via optimal transport but essentially
you get a convex extension and you can
do exact optimization for that convex
extension you can also do a reduction to
the set functions in certain cases so
many of the ideas generalize the
convexity and concavity ideas so you can
in some cases also use now discrete
optimization to solve continuous non
convex optimization problems that's when
this is most useful let me just skip
this and it has certain applications in
robust mostly in robust non convex
optimization and learning problems ok
that's sort of just to show you a little
bit that it can also go the other way
around that the ideas are actually more
general I will skip this part I wanted
to just mention there's also other
interesting connections of sub
modularity negative dependence and the
theory of real stable polynomials but we
have certain lots of experts here
there's NEMA there's in the sheet and
there's Nikhil and chai and also so
these are good people to talk to about
these things so let me just jump to the
conclusion ok so what I showed you was a
little bit of sort of on topic of
connections between discrete and
continuous optimization how you can use
convex and concave aspect both of a
certain class of discrete optimization
problems to get good relaxations and
good approximation algorithms or exact
optimization algorithms out and moreover
even up to certain non convex
imitation problems that you can solve
with the same ideas that thanks for your
listening and I'll be available for
questions in the break up
[Applause]
it's only in the black box right I mean
the only access to your punishment yes I
know whatever I mean do any of this
research
okay so what in certain cases you can
get better results so for example in the
convex case you can get faster
optimization so if you think about like
the minimum cut problem you actually
after graph you can even get a
polynomial time algorithm you if you
have say something that looks like some
of functions of easier functions you can
use this can get better faster
algorithms out by using actually that
decomposition structure for example so
in that case it used to it leads to
faster algorithms in the maximization
case you can sometimes get better
approximation algorithms if you think of
the max cut problem it's better than a
proximal build and a half which is the
lower bound for like black box general
submodular minimization maximization so
you essentially can use more of the
structure of the problem to get better
optimization fast optimization or better
approximation results essentially yes
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]